What's your opinion on subgrade minerals, subgrade minerals?
Also on going to cancer conferences.
I was going to Dr. Arnis's workshop, but not sure if I should veer off my protocol.
I'm not sure what subgrade minerals are.
The type of minerals that you should use are minerals that are bound the same way that they are in plants.
And in animals, if you eat the minerals that you would get even in beef and things.
But you get most of your minerals through plants.
And minerals in plants are bound or double bonded to an amino acid.
So that's the way you should consume minerals.
The worst thing, I don't know what subgrade minerals are, but what's really has been popular in the last few years are these liquid minerals and these, you know, these sea based minerals, coral, coral sea minerals.
And that kind of stuff, that's ridiculous. You don't have to eat dirt.
That's the plants eat dirt and they convert that soil based mineral into an amino acid double bonded mineral.
And then we consume that and that's well absorbed and well utilized.
We're not supposed to eat soil based minerals.